and then even even like governments pay
out single mothers they don't pay out
single fathers
but don't you think there's something
then that's something wrong with the
system because like i said previously
when i was date when i was dating that
type person who had two kids you know
there were times where
he was a good father and there were
times where he would
go into the court like go to court and
try and you know get joint custody of
his kids and it would be so hard yes
like that it would be so difficult
almost impossible and it went on for
years
and and then and then you hear and then
you do hear stories of women who go to
court and they do get that favor they do
that's but that's but that's
the court system that we currently have
right yeah that's what i'm saying it's
like that's another way women are bailed
out of bad decisions because they can
leave break up the home and they still
get custody
on the chick and a check
and even and women own two-thirds of
consumer debt right so we get homeless
what are their women's shelters
there's not really men's shelters like
that i mean there's like one or two but
not not the same way there's women's
shelters that's true i don't even know
what i don't know what the real-time
like
real-time data is for that
in the uk if you're a woman and you have
a child out of wedlock and you're
homeless yeah you get counsel house so
quick quick if you're single if you're a
single dad they'll tell you to get a job
big man and sort it out or your kids are
going into care yeah you're not getting
council house like that yeah that's but
i think that's a massive flaw in again
the system is
it's not a flaw in the system because
the system is made for men to work
in order to put into the system and
allow women
to cash out of the system so when people
talk about flaws it's it's not a flaw
it's how the system's going to work and
obviously as as pearl has been saying
like
women are 80 of the consumer base so
they know the system knows that if men
are working and putting into the system
the women are going to take the money
out and spend it on these luxuries that
you that women love you know bags
clothes and you know women are very
spontaneous with their spending do you
understand so and like when we talk
about for example the welfare state and
we talk about general double standards
this is not us as
us as men advocating that the double
standards shouldn't exist
our problem is we accept these double
standards like no man who pays on a
first date
is bothered
unless you're a broke guy and you're a
loser and you probably don't deserve
[ __ ] anyway but most men
are not bothered but but our problem is
when a man now comes out and says
cheating for a man and woman is
different or then women just lose the
plot about it and it becomes a double
standard conversation and that's why
when we talk about this is that
okay women talk about how
there's this pay gap but it's it's
invisible it's just because men do the
harder jobs that get most of the rewards
so it's like women choose
to go to the education system they're
not blocked from going to the education
system
most women achieve better than men
pretty much through every single aspect
of education
more women go to university than men but
who becomes the corporate bankers who
becomes the lawyers it's the men not the
women it's not because there's a window
there it's very simple with
it's it's risk versus reward do the
harder job you get paid more of the
money do you think that's because like
women are expected to
when once they have a child to stay at
home look after the child and they they
kind of
they have they have to
you know lead a certain lifestyle in
order to support their family i disagree
with that yeah i do i do why do you i'm
just curious i'm just curious why do we
always say have to instead of get two
yeah you ever ever think about that
because it's a privilege to get to stay
home with your kids yeah definitely the
majority of women don't get to do that
it's like maybe 20 of women get to be
housewives so unless you're in the top
20 of like hotness looks like whatever
you probably don't get to stay home you
probably have to work yeah so to me if
there's nothing getting in women's way
like
there's nothing stopping them if they
want to do it they do it yeah
i can't dispute i think like this day
and age you can
choose to or not and also with that like
you have um women
essentially
what do they have it so if a ma if a
woman gets pregnant the man can take
it's not uh potentially but he can take
paternity yeah it's like six it's like
six weeks out if you're at a really good
firm where as women it's like six to
nine months in the uk so like they're
making caveats to ensure that there's
some form of equality so it doesn't mean
that a woman has to take
time off completely
so
and i really going on what you're saying
in a lot of forward-thinking firms
now because of the whole gender-neutral
lgbtq movement they've now made oh you
get maternity and paternity but it's
shed
so
there's no it's not like oh the man now
only gets six weeks and a woman only
gets six months it's now shared you get
this amount of holiday
and then
you get to pick that between
whoever
i think that's i think that's really
good
okay so we're gonna react to a video um
so pull up the one from the dating
show-ish
um you guys may have seen this clip this
went viral a couple weeks ago
uh yeah i was actually reading um
i ship out in a few days so i was just
reading the artist strategy
okay
uh yeah so actually i'm a nuclear
physicist for the navy
so i'll do that in a few in a few
how about days
i am 27. i look a little young i'm not
that young
so where do you live
uh so i'm actually in the woodlands
texas right now
um right right down there by houston i'm
about 30 minutes away from houston so
i'm a little close
oh nice okay so tell me a little bit
about yourself
um
man where do i start uh
i like uh i like martial arts a lot i
did a bit of pharmacy uh
back when i was a little bit younger
about two three years ago i got
certified at pharmacy around when i was
17. um i didn't really do anything with
it i went to university for a while i
was getting like a business degree so i
have a bachelor's in business and then i
did um pharmacy for a little while for
about three years and then
got bored so i was like ah let's go see
what the military has to offer it didn't
do anything um
got my
i did my pie cat about a year ago got a
96 on that it goes up to a 99 got a 96
they offered me nuclear physics and i
was like why the [ __ ] not so i went
there and
now i ship out in a few days
oh okay nice well best of luck as you
ship out pineapples
yeah
why because he literally didn't tell me
any qualities about himself he's just
like i made a 96 on this i did this and
i feel like i did that at first too
but however i knew a man wasn't
personality
you felt that quick you know you didn't
have personality yeah i'm really good at
reading people
okay
well that's more that's more than women
yeah okay so
so so so
i think that's an age thing though she's
if she had a you she wouldn't think like
that she definitely doesn't have kids
no yeah yeah that's true right but
so
my question is
again that's another like she's acting
like a child because she's putting like
personality and vibes over the logical
thing which is is this guy gonna be a
good husband
um what are your initial reactions when
we go around um i felt like um
you could see that she wasn't impressed
she looked like she just
was a bit bored um and as you said as
well i feel like
you could see that she's quite
young minded and also you could see what
her preference really was just by even
the way she talked and how she looked
i'm not trying to be judgmental that but
that's what i got from it
the guy to me sounded very intelligent
and very had ambition and you know
seemed like a good guy